but let's bring you some other breaking
news a metropolitan police officer could
face criminal charges over the fatal
shooting of Chris Cava after the police
Watchdog handed over evidence to the
crown prosecution service Mr Kappa was
killed by a single shot fired through
the windscreen of his car in September
last year here's what the iopc had to
say in the last half hour
today we've referred a file of evidence
to the crown prosecution service
following the conclusion of our homicide
investigation into the fatal shooting of
Chris caber by a Metropolitan Police
Service Officer on the 5th of September
2022 in streatham Hill South London
this was a tragic incident and our
investigators have been working hard to
ensure our comprehensive investigation
has been completed without undue delay
and within the six to nine month time
frame that we have committed
Chris Capper died after he was struck by
a single gunshot fired by a Metropolitan
Police Service Officer into the vehicle
he was driving
during the investigation the officer was
advised that they were under criminal
investigation for murder and following
the conclusion of our investigation we
have referred a file of evidence to the
crown prosecution service to determine
whether to charge the officer
a referral to the crown prosecution
service does not necessarily mean
criminal charges will follow
it is now for the crown prosecution
service to decide applying the code for
Crown prosecutors whether or not to
prosecute the officer
Mr kaba's family and the officer
involved have been notified of this
development
our thoughts remain with everyone
affected by this incident
whilst guys shingi mariki joins us now
from South London with more and she just
remind us a little bit of the background
to this
well after an eight-month investigation
the iopc that independent regulator have
decided to refer this case to the crown
prosecution service that means the
current prostitution service will take
the decision whether to charge this
officer and coming back to the
background you just asked about this
incident took place in 5th of September
last year Chris Cabra 24 year old was
driving through South London in an Audi
which had been linked to a Firearms
incident the day before he was then
picked up by officers who didn't know it
was him who was driving he was also
unarmed and they followed him for 15
minutes through South London with no
lights or Sirens then while waiting in
in the road in which she was going into
there was another police car A Marked
vehicle out of that vehicle got a got
out of an officer called nx21 in this
case they fired a single shot through
his windscreen that shot killed Chris
caber and that incident has obviously
led to deep unrest amongst his family
and protests across the country as well
a grieving family forced to campaign all
organize events and try to get Justice
for their assignment in this moment now
they feel that one of the things they
were demanding the prospect of the
officer being charged has been fulfilled
we spoke with family earlier Jefferson
the family spokesperson who was really
relieved but also happy to see this
moment Karma now they're going to start
putting pressure on the CPS and asking
them to conclude their findings but I
think it's worth noting that this could
take a while we spoke to the families
lawyer who said that this could
potentially take a few months so a
length fee legal journey ahead for the
family but this is one outcome that they
wanted
Shinji thank you very much